georgians are starting to hit the polls
this morning you see for the first day
of early voting for the state's
pivotal senate runoffs president-elect
joe biden will headline a rally there
tomorrow to boost
support for democrats rafael warnock and
john ossoff
they are looking to unseat incumbent
republican senators kelly lafleur and
david perdue
this is a very significant race because
these two runoff elections will
determine which party controls
the u.s senate stacey abrams a democrat
and founder of the voting rights
organization fair fight
joins us now to discuss good morning to
you stacey abrams good to see you big
day in georgia too today as the early
voting begins
good morning and we're very excited i'm
i was wondering about your excitement
listen you had a record
of five million people who voted in
georgia
turning this presidential election for
the first time in a very long time blue
but this time
president trump and president-elect joe
biden are not on the ballot
so how in the world do you keep the
momentum going
because coveted relief is on the ballot
access to jobs access to justice
and there's a very stark contrast
between the candidates
we have kelly leffler and david perdue
who profited off of the pandemic
who refused to stand up to mitch
mcconnell and demand action on covet
relief
as we head into a moment where georgians
face 160
000 evictions we've had 4.1 million
job loss claims one in four businesses
small businesses have shut down during
this pandemic
and david and kelly have done nothing in
fact they have done nothing but
cater to mitch mcconnell and donald
trump instead of fighting for georgia
but rafael warnock and john ossoff will
go to d.c
they will deliver on the promise of
covert relief for georgians they will
make certain that in particular
communities of color
that are facing a disproportionate
effect of not only the loss of lives
but the loss of livelihoods that they
will have access to the relief
that so many people are desperate to
have but what's even more important to
me
is that the president of the united
states the incoming president will have
a balanced
senate that he can work with to get
things done instead of an avowed
obstructionist like mitch mcconnell
who has made it his pledge that nothing
gets done
while joe biden is in office well you
make a good case for the
for your two candidates stacy but
everybody says the turnout is always low
when we have these kind of elections
and that it's just an uphill battle to
climb even with the candidates that you
speak so highly of you know
purdue and lafleur still have a lot of
support out there
of course they do this is a state that
is almost evenly divided the
presidential election was decided by
fewer than 12 000 votes
but what's at stake isn't divisive
what's at stake is making sure that we
have relief for our communities
and we know that people are taking this
seriously 1.2 million georgians have
already requested
absentee ballots 1.3 million requested
ballots during the november election
but what's so exciting is embedded in
that number of that 1.2 million
85 000 of those applications for mail-in
ballots
come from voters who didn't vote in
november and they are disproportionately
voters between the ages of 18 and 29 and
disproportionately people of color
and when we start early voting today we
have every belief that we're going to
see a turnout that is unlike anything
georgia has seen
we have the investment we have the
momentum and what's so
important is that we have a mission and
that is to serve georgians by sending
two real
servants to dc well vice president pence
is urging republicans to not only vote
early but vote by absentee ballots
that certainly is a big turnaround from
what we had in the presidential election
do you think their strategy will work
this time
will make a difference i don't know i
know i'm not sure i
i don't try to dissuade anyone from
voting and certainly not from voting by
mail
but donald trump has spent the last
month doing nothing but undermining the
political the
electoral system in georgia just last
night he sent out another tweet
undermining the system and unfortunately
we know that it has had an effect on
certain voters my belief is though that
there are enough voters who want
progress who want good for their
families who are going to suffer through
this
season of cheer by trying to figure out
if they can put food on the table
and that's the kind of thing that we
need to be talking about
we need to talk about what the future
looks like and the only way we're going
to get to that future
is if we replace mitch mcconnell and if
we have two new u.s senators
who are going there not only to work for
georgia but to work for
a better america well the president as
you know has not conceded the race
certainly hasn't conceded in georgia and
republican officials are
are comparing his refusal to concede to
your refusal to concede
when you ran for governor of georgia is
that a fair comparison
not at all let's begin with the fact
that i acknowledged the legal
sufficiency of the election
in my speech that was the first thing
that i did i refused to concede
a system that stole votes from georgians
was legitimate
and the problem was i was right we had
four cases
every single one of those cases was
decided in favor of georgia voters
i never contested the election to make
myself a governor
i contested the election to make certain
that every vote was counted
and every voter was heard as opposed to
making up wholesale lies
and pushing for a notion of widespread
fraud that has been dismissed
by 58 different courts all right stacy i
know that right now you're concentrating
on this senate race but listen
that's over in january so what are your
plans after that
will we see stacey abrams on the ballot
for governor again
in the next election my my focus
is getting people to go to peachvote.com
to make a plan to vote
on january 5th and i'm looking at the
future stacey abrams what is the future
hold for stacey
i know what you're doing now the future
the future holds making certain that we
send john ossoff and rafael warnock
to dc to make sure we get good done
that's what i'm thinking about that's
what i'm focused on and that's going to
be my mission
all right stacy abrams i know we will
talk again thank you so much for your
time i know you got a lot of work to do
today thanks gail thank you